buenas noches a los compatriotas del
continente de ultramar en este periodo
tan incierto al salir de una crisis
sanitaria importante y ahora que tenemos
nuevamente guerra en europa ustedes
fueron llamados a llamar a votar este
domingo para la primera vuelta de la
elección presidencial este 10 de abril
de 2022 quiero enviar un saludo
republicano al pueblo los electores y
agradecer calurosamente a todos aquellos
y aquellas que me honraron con su voto
sé que algunos de ustedes o muchos están
decepcionados esta tarde y todos haremos
el balance de esta jornada de manera
objetiva pero ustedes saben que nunca
bajamos los brazos yo nunca dejaré de
luchar a todos aquellos con quienes
estuve en francia a todos aquellos por
quienes lucho
sobre todo a los de la primera fila les
hago un llamado para que nuestro país
sigan que los obreros los enfermeros los
agricultores
y todos aquellos y aquellas que también
le dan la vida a nuestro bello país con
su creatividad con su generosidad y con
sus compromisos quiero decirles
bajo juramento les digo hoy que pondré
toda mi energía de mujer política y
ciudadana para tener una francia
republicana más fuerte y más bella y más
justa
[Aplausos]
al terminar esta primera vuelta tanto
los resultados y la abstención en
particular nos muestran que francia está
dividida y tiene muchas fracturas que
estaban enfrentadas a una extrema
derecha a las fuerzas del poder entonces
como es el compromiso de toda mi vida
por la república y para que francia no
pase al al odio de todos contra todos
con mucha gravedad les hago un llamado
para que el próximo 24 de abril voten en
contra de la extrema derecha imagen de
feng haciendo uso de
la papeleta de votación
emanuel smartphone
[Aplausos]
queridos compatriotas
este voto republicano es una elección
una decisión de responsabilidad no borra
para nada sus angustias no borra para
nada la urgencia de actuar por el clima
tampoco la sed de justicia
que se ha expresado en esta campaña
esta decisión no borra para nada mis
convicciones de mujer de izquierda ni mi
determinación de luchar por la república
por la democracia por la justicia social
y por la ecología esa será mi lucha
nuestro combate a partir de mañana será
nuestro combate volver a darles a
nuestros jóvenes la esperanza en el
futuro proteger nuestra economía de las
competencias liberales que no tienen fe
ni ley de ayudar a la salud pública y
toda la educación de la república laica
y social de continuar con la
construcción de europa por la paz y por
un apoyo más activo aún al pueblo
ucraniano
esa será nuestra lucha lucha implacable
no obstaculizar este proyecto injusto de
la
jubilación a 65 años de la privatización
rampante de la escuela de la universidad
de la salud de la estigmatización de los
más pobres y de los desempleados y de la
falta de acción por el clima queridos
compatriotas usted saben cuál es mi
determinación y les digo aquí está
estaremos la izquierda republicana y
europea social y ecologista la izquierda
de lo real la izquierda que siempre ha
permitido el progreso social en nuestro
país esa izquierda a la vamos a
reconstruir fuerte creativa popular
abierta a los sindicatos a los
movimientos sociales a la generosidad de
todos aquellos y aquellas que se
comprometen y esto comenzará desde el
día siguiente de la elección
presidencial con las legislativas a
todos aquellos y aquellas que se
reconocen en esta izquierda que ya está
actuando y que actúa conjuntamente en
los territorios
ayuden a apoyar estos candidatos para
favorecer la justicia social y la
justicia climática luego trabajaremos
por la reunión de esta izquierda
dispersa que no suponerse cuando era
necesario
esto con las fuerzas sociales y
asociados asociativas trabajaremos para
restablecer estos vínculos vitales de
confianza con las clases populares las
clases medias y devolverle la fuerza de
encarnar una nueva esperanza y una
alternativa para mañana si allí
estaremos y yo estaré allí para
devolverle la el orgullo a una izquierda
moderna abierta de todos los colores que
tiene creatividad porque sin esta
izquierda la francia que amamos la
francia republicana la francia
democrática social laica y europea no
puede cumplir sus promesas de libertad
igualdad y fraternidad
entonces viva la república y viva
francia muchas gracias
[Aplausos]